how are you good big tester yours no
yeah read never done something like that
before so yeah thinking feeling bit
about me comfort zone unknown to you
you've actually been tested twice I sent
in my secret diner and this is what
happened on the coach trip they let my
diners down with over fussy food and
service but have they learned from their
mistakes
hi there Bobby Davis for your vicious
swaps with some lack of bath and
repartee
thank you very much thank you thank you
I would not ask for these they just came
to us first off great welcome and these
Bush arrives at the table didn't ask
them gets put down and bang they start
eating you'll find three different
venues but only two are available you
have the very first one which is damage
for you and if you turn the page where
you see it read with them on the right
of the red we're going to see the
venetie priests that's the one that we
only go in the evening I can be with
excuse you have to come back on the
left-hand side that however you will
find the Ellicott which is fully
available as when we start as among
courses and then you'll find the
desserts at the back of the moonship is
in the following page and or steak the
menus big imposing shoes descriptions is
long-winded it's getting heavier and
heavier and heavier and they just want
to be left alone all right
all right right so we get another I mean
the muse bish that's three things you've
had so far that we unordered you know
beginning to feel like I've really
started to eat now Anna we haven't had
the first of our three courses I hope it
brings another feminist fish otherwise I
will be unamused bouche while is a
really nice gesture great opener sets
the tone for what's happening next but
any more than one it looks like you're
trying too hard
roasted Lobster let's when the lobster
reads up wonderful College Weezer and
Sarah was a soy kid modeled he was a
lobster best and the side the traffic
laws oh yeah the Parmesan cheese thank
you enjoy
told me he did time so annoying when he
pointed out that morel mushroom I swear
his finger is actually touched the
motion is not touched it I don't know
that's all I don't want someone coming
in in pointing a finger of my food and
all that stuff that's time bugger off
food is exquisite you need to look at
your service you need to really just
rein that in and bring a breath of fresh
air in there and you'll surprise
yourself and more importantly attract a
different clientele which you've been
slightly nervous of going for that's got
it was great to get feedback from Gordon
it was great for him to say to me you
know it's good rounds of telling you
what's great about your cooking what's
not so good about it and what to fix
about it and anyone who can say negative
things values is great because that
means we can analyze it work it do we
need to change it it's great feedback no
it is priceless